all right everyone uh thanks again for
taking time on weekend and joining for
my session uh so we're going to talk
about data science tools and ecosystem
so I puted the very very realistic and
you know realistic approach so that I
believe you not get bored for sure let's
dive in
uh okay some see marketing about me data
scientist analytics manager currently I
be a talented team of data science and
ands with my work apart from my
professional stuff I love contributing
to lot of commun so I'm involved with
the community which I listed in my slide
so where I perform different tools and
responsibilities in each of these
organizations and uh and also par
balance industry and Academia right so
apart from my professional my
contributions so I also uh I te um
academ platforms like some platforms and
some Community platforms like you know
great City KAG and also top so where I
be different and mentoring different
stuff other than that you know I love to
watch of movies going to Mountain for
yeah making my
business in order to Rel all this Stu
yes right so if you have any questions
or any feedback
for me so to get all these platforms
which are listed here so I'll be happy
to address all your questions whatever
the thing for me I respond you
message so so before we actually talk
about the DAT tools and ecosystem I
thought of know talking about some of
the myths which are there in data from
long time but still a lot of people have
a confusion about this things so I'll
try to talk about each of them
so data science is not just about big
data so most believe that you know data
science is solely rols around the
handling vast amount of data but in
reality it involves various
aspects apart from handling volume like
you know including your data quality
analysis interpretation you know
deriving insights from various dates so
not only just that data science too and
data science is fully automated and
replace human decision making I'm sure
I'm sure there is a lot of B about this
on internet as well I believe that know
a lot of people still who are who are
there here also have same question in
their month but let me tell you that
know data science tools and AI will
definitely not replace human
judgment but uh but in reality data
science tools and AI tools will play a
crucial role in decision making but they
don't replace human judgment because all
these tools are there in help or in
assist in providing insights but uh
women judgment you know understanding
the situation and critical ethically
critical thinking
are are are really important for making
informed decision so that is something
that know AI cannot replace so one thing
you should remember that you know uh uh
without human intelligence there is no
artificial intelligence right and uh you
need to you need expensive tools for
doing data science so yeah a lot of
people believe that we need to have
expensive software and tools for doing
data science in real time but but in
reality it's not like that because we
have a lot of big open ecosystem and lot
of libraries lot ofes are available on
free you just need to late them and you
can start doing the data sign that you
don't to
buyt uh and next one is solve every
business problem uh yeah most people
believe that data solve data sign solve
each and every business problem but to
make it work we need to have the right
questions and you know we need to have a
good quality data it's not something
that you are having tools but it's about
how you are using that and information
that how it really matters like you know
how you are taking for forward it really
matters so that's also it's not
something where every problem can
solve and finally data science is just a
trend and we soon PA
away the the def for data science is
rapidly growing across different
Industries because every industry is
adopting data science practices in real
time right so so data science is a
foundation skills for you know analyzing
and you know uh
interpreting from the data from this
from the huge amounts of data that we
generating in to well so it's really
found the SK and you know all your job
is something that you def something not
going to pay away it will definitely sa
for sure but one important thing which
you have to keep in your mind here is
the spe is like you know continuously
evolving so in order to stay or in order
to be continuously stay in the market
right on the trend so you need to par
upscale yourself so that know you be in
the
race now what exactly is the data
science so before I actually talk about
data science let me tell you something
uh let's talk about data first then
we'll talk about the science underlying
sence behind it then we'll try to
combine everything called
Data so if you see the screenshot which
I mentioned in my slide right so in 2023
we are almost like you know uh we are
generating
32877 million terabytes data per day so
this is something like you even my hands
are shorter to show you that know how
big this data we are generating in day
right so so so that's a lot of data and
I believe that it's not something
surprising for me
because uh the every device that we are
using generate data and the interaction
that we are also making with those
devices generate even more data for
example uh if you take a mobile and you
click a selfie picture of yours that is
generating data if you trying to read an
article or a block post through your
iPad or your your tablet that generating
the
data or right now you are attending my
talk through the zoom platform that is
also generating the data right so there
is so much of data so there is no wonder
that know generating 38.7 Milli data so
it's like you know we are generating
data like this
simple the only thing I believe that
where we are not generating data is our
brief but still I believe that it's
debatable because considering all smart
gears that we are wearing today for
example I'm wearing a smart watch that
is something where it keep tracking me
from my hard PSE to my Cal
B might also captured right so so we are
collecting huge data generating huge
data now what are we doing with all this
data are we making sense of it in
reality right only 50% and lot of
Industries or lot of report studies says
that only 50% of the data is being ized
and converted into a meaningful
Insight the important thing which we
have to remember here is we need to make
use of all the data that they
generating so how do we do that so there
are some effective ways to do it okay
there are some effective ways that we
can Implement to do it effectively in
order to make use of all this data so
this is where your data science comes
into the picture right so when we
talking about data science right so
there are lot of definitions that we
have about data science on the internet
so my way of telling data science is it
is a science of being able to leverage
from data to create some added value to
The Domain that you are applying the
data on right so for example consider a
raw data consider a broad data like this
and converting into a meaningful Insight
generating
our so data science is about using data
and creating as much imp part to your
organization for as much how much impact
creating in the data your organization
that is the data because so when so when
it comes to the impact so it can be
different form for example your data
applications or it can be data products
or you doing some product
recommendations or creating some
visual inss so it depends upon the
problem and end of the that you want to
solve but essentially uh the goal of a
data scientist is to solve a real world
business
problem and of the company uh end of the
day nobody cares that know what kind of
tools you're using to solve the problem
right so it's all about how you are
solving the problem it's not about what
kind of the tools you are using there
are only specific where we fly Focus
that we need this specific to that that
is where we highlight to but in reality
nobody ask that no you solve the
business problem what can of TOS you
have used there something nobody asks in
real time right so that is something you
should keep in
mind again when we talk about data
science right so there are three areas
uh that have been involved in data
science I'm sure everybody has aware of
this diagram of data science s so data
science is an intersection between three
areas like you know your domain
expertise your computer science and your
mathematics and statistics so so you can
see how it is bringing the gap between
this how the how these three areas are
bring the gap between the different
kinds to to further understanding of the
data that we hold so these three
principles are like you know
collaborativ with work in order to
successfully do the data science problem
that we also see in detail last coming
slides now I believe that I know you got
a very fair understanding about what
data science is how what exactly the
data science do
right now let's talk about the types of
the data science that we do uh so we
have a different methods uh for dealing
different questions that we might ask in
an organization so these questions can
be vary by you know the complexity and
the value that we are expecting out of
them so let me try to explain you
through the visual example and I'll also
try to explain you through to with the
use case that know how we can solve the
problem right how we can try to
understand all these methodologies with
the usec case so since I work with sales
and marketing domain so I try to Pi one
of the sales use case like know sales
forecasting and I'll try to walk you
through the different methods of doing J
here so the first method here is
descripting or it also called as a
descriptive an so this is really
something that you know what is
happening in my so uh so it involves
like you know uh
handling handling quality collection of
data to make sure that we know what's
happening in our business so so the
question the interesting question that
you can ask here is do do my sales go up
or down so in order to identify that you
need this is where your second method
comes into the picture which is called
Diagnostics or diagnostic antics so this
is something like you know what if
something happened in my business so did
my sales go up or down so in order to
identify that so this is the process
where we try to dig down to understand
the root cause of our problem so we try
to undery whether my going up or not so
how do we this is where through
diagnostical we do diagnos and try to
understand problem so once you identify
the r of problem you try to predict
which is nothing but predictive anties
of predict so so as a name itself S
suggest that you're are trying to
predict what's going to happen next so
what going to happen my sales in the
next qu so how my sales will to improve
increase in next quarter or next year
how we going to do that how we going to
identify that so it involves you know
where you are trying to bring your
historical data and try to make
predictions out of it so your prediction
will say whether which got increased
decreased so that's how you get to know
through pred and so once you're done
with the prediction prescriptive
analytics so you got your predictions
now what I'm going to do next so what is
the outcome that I got so what kind of
actions plans that I can make in order
to improve my business further let's say
how can I improve my sales performance
by 15% next quarter but next year so
this is where you some picture try to
strategy and start impr business again
you come back to the first step so these
are the different types of data science
method that you use to solve the real
world data science problem in real time
right this is exactly how we try to
solve the use case in a real time so I
think with this you got a fair idea
about what data science is how we can do
data science in real time now let's uh
talk about uh data science ecosystem so
when we talking about the ecosystem of a
data science right so it usually starts
with
a business understanding so this is
something really important right uh so
this is because this is a place where
you try to ask the right questions and
so this is place where your business
expertise and your domain expertise
comes into
where they try to ask the right
questions uh so if you want to take your
data science initiative further right so
this is a place where you try to
formulate the right questions to
understand the problems and you know
kick start your data science Pro Journey
right so once you identified that the
next step is data mining so this is the
step where you try to procure the data
so you try to collect the data from your
databases or you try to St the data from
internet or sometimes you also try to
get the data from your third parties
depending upon the business problem that
you are trying to solve so once you
collected the data right so the next
step is to clean the data right so there
is a saying that a lot of data
scientists spend most of the time in
doing data cleaning and preparation
which is indeed true because uh the real
time data is completely messed it's not
it doesn't look something like you know
your K data sets where you know you have
a nice CSV format you just need to put
the data and you need to write some mod
and make predictions that is something
uh that is
something so it doesn't look like
something in real time right so in lot
of academic your data is completely
formatted you just need to use it and
but in real time the data is completely
messy like you know like you know it's
scattered widely so you need to bring
first you need to all this data then you
start doing lot ofle so in this process
right so you might have some missing
values you might see some duplicate you
also see lot of out layers in the data
so this is where you start applying your
data analysis and your data Techni to
make your data clean forther analyses
right so that is why it take a lot of
time the better you clean the data right
the better your analysis output will be
so that is the reason we spend a lot of
time here uh to to try to analyze the
data in a perfect way right so once you
done with the data then you start
exploring so this is where you try to
apply some of your uh uh some of your
analytical tools to and some of the
business question that I talked about in
earlier slide like know when we talk
about data so I Tred to formate some
question so with this you try to do some
of try to answer some of this question
but again if you want to answer a
business question in a very high level
value right Val so this is where you are
your machine learning and AI comes into
the picture for instance so you don't
that machine learning so you need to
have a very massive quality data at the
same time you also need to have a
competing power uh to make the machine
learning models work right so so this is
the stage where you try to build your
machine learning models you try to
deploy your models and you try to
continuously monitor your models
effectively once deoy production
so so this is how it works so once you
have done this entire process and
finally you try to visualize that right
so you try to communicate the results of
your outcomes to your stakeholders so
that you know they can look at the
results and some of the build some
strategy and also try to improve the
business further so so one thing you
have to remember here is is it's not
something like you know start and end
process it's an iterative process so
data science is like an iterative
process so once you visualiz once
communicate the result then you try to
improve further then again you come back
to problem and you try to streamline the
process you try to even work better to
improve your set so it's like a complete
iterative process it's not something a
stag
process so now you got a fair
understanding about how the ecosystem
works now now I want to talk about
who does what in this lead system right
so let me so in anation so we may have
people like you know the business
analyst data analyst or data scientist
or even data Engineers BL okay so what
does business do so
business totally work with like you know
business understanding so they have a
solid domain expertise they are good in
formulating questions because they know
how to ask right questions how to
formate the right question for the
problem and partly business and also try
to work on communicating the insights to
stakeholders because they have a solid
business knowledge right so they can
also be great helpful in communicating
the insights to
stakeholders now what data analyst do so
data analyst so do data mining data
cleaning exploration so so these are the
people like you know who we collect the
data we try to clean and do lot of data
analysis preparation and make it ready
for forther analysis so this is where
lot of data anal perform the job when it
comes to data scientist so this is where
they do like you know once record
complete like you know data like you
know analysis perfect data they start
build models if the models and monitor
Machine model working and they also par
help us in communicating inside the
stakeholders right but now I'll tell you
something interesting here that in
today's Marketplace and reality how it
is working is uh uh your business
analyst uh sometimes has to work on
machine learning models your data
analyst or your data scientist has to
start work everything from your business
understanding to your communicating ins
so it's not something that the thing
which I showcase is not fixed but in
reality today how it's happening is
business doing machine learning data
scientific is starting start working
understanding from business problem data
is also sometimes machine learning so
why all these things are happening means
because it depends upon the scale and
the people in the SES and the people in
the organization not every organization
will have like you know business hand
data an data Eng product Engineers or
product analyst right uh right software
Engineers right so because uh every
company does not have that much of like
investment toire too many people for
instance if you ask me how is a very
small team so as a data scientist and so
par apart from leading my team I also
start as a data SST my job is to start
working from understanding a business
problem to delivering a project and
communicating things such a stakeholder
so I have to do everything from SC there
is no other option there are no other
people who try to do
this because of the lack of resources
and because of the size of the company
right so that's how it's happening so
it's good to have a d skills uh so that
you know you'll be like you know good
lead or know you will be like you know
good stand out in the market for sure so
so now that you got a CLE understanding
about how data science ecosystem can
help us like you
know starting from you know picking
understanding the business problem from
noisy data to con the business
stakeholder so this is how exactly this
is how exactly we try to use for solve
business problems in real
time
okay uh now when yeah one important
point which I forgot to miss is so all
these folks needs collaboration because
it is critical to have a collaboration
between business andal data data an and
your stakeholder because what's
happening within this entire data
product should be aware of if there is a
communication gra between these people
then it will be completely mess and your
product will do away again you have to
come back you lose all your efforts time
and everything lot of lot of data
science projects today face because of a
lot of communication between differents
now it's been improved slowly but
earlier like you know it was a big M
initially when I started my data SCI I
didn't know all this things it's like
you know the only thing which I have in
my mind is like you know okay I got the
data let's me let's start doing some
coding let's start building some model
that's it I didn't know about
understanding of the content the
criticality of understanding business
problem collaboration between the so
down the line and gradually include
improve and understand the reality
to conclude this slide that it's really
important to have a collaboration
between all these te that is the reason
why if you remember the first run
diagram of a data so it's an
intersection between all this things in
mathematic coding doain expertise and
your and so all of these different
people work together come together to
solve the Rel problem so collaboration
really not
here when it comes to tools for data
scientist right so there are tons of
tools if you go if you go and search in
a Google right it will show you like
know these much of list right but in
reality and based on my experience so
these are like you know go to tools for
data science and uh these are like you
know day-to-day tools that a lot of data
scientists use in real time in the
industry uh so programming language
programming language and required
libraries uh so you need to familiar
with the programming language like SQL
then python or or Oria chulia is also
picking up in dat these days so it's not
really required to have a knowledge in
all the three like you know python Julia
but SQL for sure the reason behind is if
you are not sure where your data is
sitting then there is no point of that
you're working on data so it's really
important that you should familiar where
your data is sitting that is the reason
why you need to know the knowledge of
aale so in terms of programming like you
know pyth so you can pick any
programming language and you can start
doing writing important necessary
libraries and start doing so in order to
do this so we need also need to have a
integrated developer environments right
so so most widely used are like you know
jupter notebooks and vs Cod but again
you can you can choose different idas
like you know for example pyam you can
use spider and also blah blah it depends
but personally uh as far as I know and
we we also use is like you know having
notb and
code and next is like you know
Enterprise that data platform so so so
we also need to have some Enterprise
data platforms like it can be uh your
databas data mind and so these are these
platforms have help us to streamline and
scalable our data science work for
optimization so it's good to ENT lot of
organ still have some ENT data Platforms
in okay next we need to have a business
intelligence software uh so in order to
create dashboards and reports so it's
good to have like you know have a
software like powerbi tabl so all these
are widely used in industry so it's up
to organization choice that whichever to
they want to choose but these are like
you know wi
re next is like viral control so if you
want to make changes some changes in
code and you want to work in some
collaborative CH of project so verion is
really important so so as far as I know
and that
know while control system I don't know
if there is any other version control
system right and yeah Cloud platforms
areed because since we deal with large
amount of data in real time so it's
really important that you know we have
Cloud where we try to depl model so you
cannot see something you cannot do on
your Prem site so it's really we need to
have platforms where we can deploy our
models and so it's all like paper part
so again all these are like you know top
Cloud leaders in the market so it's
again organization decision that know
which CL platform you want to use again
when it comes to learning process so you
don't need to like you know learn all
these things so at least if if you are
familiar with one of them right that is
enough to Kickstart things for example
if you
a cloud right so you can easily work on
ascp so the process remains with only
like you know here and there some
functions and the way of the UI and you
know picking the options and doing
something things are different but the
concept so that is something you should
keep in
mind now when choosing tools right so
this is these are something that you
should be uh like you know should have
some understanding while you are picking
the tools for your organization so first
thing is like you know task oriented so
this is something like you know you
should specifically pick the tools that
based on the task that you like you know
so uh so it can be like you know based
on the factors like you know like you
know size of the data and the complexity
and the Des outcome that you want to
acheve from it but based on that you can
try to pick the tools that you
want and next is domain specific so if
you want to particularly solve some
domain specific problem so you need to
have some different of tools for example
let's take Finance so if you want to try
to solve some Finance machine learning
problem right so if you you try to
Simply import like you know tools like
or pack like C Lear that is something
you cannot solve it so you also try to
import some Financial packages or you
are trying to some Financial time you
need import some time bring some time
Feld package there and when it comes to
data you also try to get the data from
different sources side so TOS depending
upon the problem that you are trying to
work so you need to choose those domains
that and finally open source commercial
so again uh again you have to choose the
limitations and requirements based on
your buet and your desired result and
your outcomes So based on these factors
you try to pick
up that you want to Cho some open source
tools or whether you need to buy some So
based on that you try to S out it and
you bring those tools and try to solve
your problem so that's how I think
Varity works like this
in so I think I thought of showing you
one of the example that we installed in
real time so the object is to not walk
you through the problem that we solved
but the object of keeping this light to
Showcase you that know how we solve this
particular problem in real time by using
these tools so the problem was like you
know optimiz in customer acation
campaign so so so I cannot R the company
name because considering the company
policies and everything so let me put it
like something aex so they they want to
maximize that return on investment by
I customer campaigns by likely that you
know which customers are likely to
convert so that is something they want
to figure out so so these are the tools
that we use to solve this problem so
I'll tell you how so the data was like
you know sitting in their databases so
the customer databases it was like
completely Miss so so we have WR lot ofq
quiries to get the data the right format
of data that we want to solve this
business problem then again use we l the
python since we highly work on python
right so we we use Python and
different dat li like you know
and for doing our data analysis and
visualiz and stuff and yeah we imported
psych plan and we build models like you
know regression and know random F to
predict the customers who are likely to
convert right so based on the result we
we TR to De the model in the Google
Cloud so where it shows that know who
are the new customers and then we also
use some automation tools
here to sending campaigns to to
customers who got brand and we converted
all the based on the result that we got
we created a report T and commun to our
customer and show what we have done and
how we have improved their our way
before working this project and after
working this problem so that's how it
has been done and yeah it was successful
earlier it was like something around %
of the and we slightly improve 20% 5% of
has been drastically increased inin six
months and still monitoring it it is
still in the monitoring phase we are
still working to improve even more
better so so so the bottom line here is
so depending upon the task that you have
to choose the tools right so there is no
structure or like a defined way that
which TOS you have to
choose so when yeah finally if you see
the feature of data science like
automated argumenting data Sciences so
so so it's like you know uh so your AI
will somehow enhance the so AI will
enhance some of your data was in future
and you can see so when there is a
increase for low code and no code tools
it will rapidly grow because of ease of
use and shift toward team oriented data
science so so you see the shift from
model building to
operationalizing models within your team
so the challenge is to make accurate and
scalable models within your organization
which is important you see that shift
Happening Now cloud computing Pres deal
with lot of amounts of data it's really
good to have cloud computing skills so
you you need to know the tools and
techniques how cloud computing helpful
in solving your data science problem so
it's really good to have the skill set
and need divers skill set why means so a
lot of data scientist today have only
software knowledge statistical knowledge
and ml knowledge so they lacking with
domain specific knowledge so it's really
good to improve your domain speci
knowledge par so that you know you will
be like you know Game Change in the
market so if you have a domain specific
knowledge and Technology knowledge then
you will be like you will be lead the
market and you also can the
sh uh advancement in the a so since you
can see the rise of andm that are likely
to make a substantial impact in data
Sciences like you know uh by Chang by
highlighting you know analys or data an
interpretation uh and you know decision
making of diverse data sets uh and
complexity so these are try to make even
more better in our data science
work uh yeah I think uh that's pretty
much that I have from my end yeah if you
have any questions anything feel free to
ask me yeah if you want to reach out to
me again these are the platforms uh you
can reach out to me and uh yeah I
appreciate if you also have any feedback
for me please write here thank you so
much see you